hey this is really really good our
friend Tim Miller a moderate Republican
who we've interviewed on the program
before
confronted Kerry Lake okay and this is
super super interesting this is from
Tim's show on Showtime he confronted
Carrie Lake and he said something that
many moderate Republicans believe which
is we should get away from this
cartoonish Maga trumpism which includes
people like Harry like and we should be
going back to moderate republicanism if
we want to win how did Kerry Lake
respond well she responded by telling
lies and by making fun of the way Tim
was dressed
that's that's what she did let's take a
look take a listen nice job here by Tim
Haley and Leo and they're saying that
we've lost three straight elections
time to change the spread
the string holders you just lost an
election what's that you to that okay
well they like to say we lost elections
we're having corrupt stolen elections
okay okay that's a lie she lost it's
very simple she lost so she's already
lying we're having corrupt stolen
elections president Trump won that
election Donald Trump did not win in
2020. there was corruption I know you
don't believe it and you don't want to
look at it delicious she did not have
the election stolen her opponent
received more votes meaning her opponent
becomes the governor I know he lost the
election because you didn't reach out to
the McCain voters
that's fake news I went to your last
event it was Steve she did Campaign hard
Mega
you weren't a million to my people
maybe you would
no that's the question it was a year
before the election when I had a
financial nuclear bomb dropped on me by
a McCain Republican
massive dump attack ads we were joking
around I said we have McCain Republicans
or America First Republicans in here and
I brought the establishment together let
me finish about the establishment
together unfortunately a few of them
didn't come over she did not bring the
establishment together she ran an
insanely divisive campaign I know you
don't believe in you refuse to look at
you refuse to look at the evidence okay
you didn't have McCain's there you
didn't have the juices they were welcome
there I I actually tried I reached out
to Ducey and I reached out to all of
those people they didn't want to come
around I can't help it but what I do
have are Independence and Democrats how
old are you I'm 41. you're 41 and you
dress like a 13 year old okay come on we
shouldn't end on it all right so that's
from the circus on Showtime which I
encourage you to check out
um so this is interesting because
there's two aspects to this layer one is
she continues telling the same lies that
have been debunked endlessly she just
keeps telling them Trump actually won I
actually won I reached out across the
aisle all these different things all of
those are lies but then it's going to
add homonyms when you have no other
choice because Tim Miller is of course
completely correct now the Practical and
strategic question going into 2024
becomes does that Dynamic remain and
which of course will damage the
Republican party and their chances or do
they realize that this Mega trumpism has
actually been quite damaging it lost
them the house in 2018.
uh it lost them everything in 2018 it
lost them the presidency it lost them
the Senate it prevented a red wave from
being what it could have been all those
different things
and do they change or do they stick with
it that's the question Adam Schiff joins
me after this short break
one of our continued sponsors is ground
news an app and website that Aggregates
local and international news sources to
show you how breaking news is being
reported around the world it has become
a go-to resource for me right now I'm
looking at a story about residents in
Ohio reporting medical symptoms after
the train derailment ground news shows
the headline from The Washington Post
owned by Jeff Bezos says East Palestine
residents should look to agent orange
victims the headline from The Epic Times
a radical right-wing Outlet says Federal
officials enter 500 East Palestine homes
after toxic train crash I also like that
you can sort things by factuality
location and bias check out ground news
for free at Ground dot News slash Pacman
if you find ground news as useful as I
do subscribe for unlimited access the
link is down below